[Music]
the pandemic has been a huge hit to our
economy and
thousands of businesses have lost
customers for others though there is a
silver lining
in canada the vast majority of
businesses are small and medium-sized
they employ most of the workers in the
private sector small and medium-sized
businesses contribute
55 percent of canada's gdp the pandemic
ground almost everything to a halt just
look at the number of jobs lost in early
2020 for example
well in may some signs of hope the
economy added 290
000 new jobs some business owners are
actually thriving
because of this pandemic and they can
barely keep up with demand
michael couture has the stories of some
of them
[Music]
they are the literal and figurative
signs of the times
everywhere you go these days you're
directed where to stand
how to move around a business by taped
arrows and decals
an interaction with sales staff is kind
of face to face
if you don't count that plexiglas
barrier the virus is unpredictable
so too are the spin-off industries that
are helping us
cope with covid19
10 weeks ago 12 weeks ago it was
pandemonium the action has leveled off
somewhat at this glass manufacturer in
ottawa
at the height of the pandemic the demand
for plexiglass was way beyond anything
tom zubkov
had seen after 40 years in the business
there has
never ever been anything like this where
all of a sudden
at the snap of fingers this had to
happen immediately there was no gradual
climbing of a hill there was no
production thoughts there was nothing
it just happened immediately and it had
to happen now or
so they started making three sizes that
could stand alone and be a barrier to
protect essential workers
business is still brisk it's just as
busy at miller mcconnell signs but that
wasn't the case at the beginning of the
pandemic when the ottawa marathon
and other major events were canceled so
too were the contracts to supply all
those signs
they had the acrylic in house so they
quickly shifted
to making face shields it was definitely
we wanted to help out the community
because we were in a position to
provide this much needed ppe but
a part of it was also trying to keep as
many people employed as possible
they're also donating hundreds to
community organizations and other
communities in the far north
weeks ago when provinces started to ease
restrictions
the core business bounced back the
changing times
meant a different type of sign is now
needed
you've probably already seen those floor
decals in nearly every store or business
you've been to lately
telling people where to stand and
helping them to keep a safe physical
distance
we've even pitched these kid-friendly
concepts to the city of ottawa
from municipal facilities as daycares
start opening up and camps and
and all that sort of stuff there's going
to be
fun colors with pictures of animals
numbers
you know go sit on this butterfly or
whatnot that kind of forward thinking is
helping some businesses boom
while others go bust during the covet 19
crisis
as the canadian economy reopens
businesses are reorienting it's believed
that will also help us get through the
recovery even as the threat of the
coronavirus remains
small businesses are guided largely by
what consumers want
and right now one of the chief things
that consumers want
is a safer experience when they're out
there doing their daily errands
and their important shopping
that could be why we're being bombarded
on social media by ads for gadgets
that'll keep us safe from covid19
from the phone sanitizer to the endless
variety of
anti-germ keys their effectiveness
remains unproven but personal protective
equipment
is in demand there is increasing
pressure to localize supply chains so
canada
isn't forced to rely on other countries
we have the technology
we have the ingenuity we have the
engineering might the manufacturing
might there's nothing
we can't build right here in ontario
enter alex dugal who's going all in
on medical masks not gonna lie it's
probably one of the scariest business
ideas
i've ever come up with scary because it
cost half a million dollars up front
he imported the mask making machine from
china so people in this country will
stop
buying masks from that country our hope
is is that canadians and governments and
businesses will support local and if our
our material and our finished product is
a comparable price to what they were
paying before
that they'll consider swapping over to a
canadian company to buy that product
his idea is to move beyond basic blue
into more colors and even customizable
for corporate logos
he's hoping to roll out these for canada
day
dugal also believes the uncertainty
around covid19
means masks will be a mainstay
eventually when everyone gets back to
going to big group events more than
likely they're going to need a face
covering
so our thought is is that we've got that
group of buyers but also at the end of
the day
healthcare needs these year-round
[Music]